whoa we await the end no no no we gotta
do some new stuff do you guys want
breaking news we gotta do some new
breaking news breaking news
breaking sad
what gilbert godfrey just passed away no
what
no way
what the hell is going on here
this is the second comedian die while
taping
wow
67.
his dirty jokes album we were talking
about it recently it's one of the best
it's one of the best albums yeah
unreal i opened for him once at
caroline's
he was struggling for the first half
hour because it's like carrie grant said
to
whatever and then
it was like all right that's funny and
then halfway in he's like i'm going
dirty and murdering
that's what they wanted and the jokes
are great
god damn it wow
that's another one gone
you know i didn't know him well but he
was always super friendly when you'd see
him soft-spoken not not what you would
think yeah
and they made a documentary about him
which is great that's another wreck god
crazy horrible i know
i'm glad i got to say i worked with him
yeah but uh i did a zoom with him during
the pandemic and i remember teasing him
and he was he was in his pajamas and i
said you look like you escaped a mental
hospital and i got a big laugh at him
and like you're like it's gilbert it's
like it feels good like he's i remember
growing up with him in the problem child
movies remember that [ __ ] yes of course
i mean that laugh was iconic
oh yeah i did jimin sam with him once
and he was he barely spoke he just
laughed he gave he gave it up for
everybody
sad man wow
we got to get a picture of him
on the wall
holy [ __ ]
67 did he have cancer
he had something i know he was ill
wow
glad we got that duck i mean you watched
that duck
and he [ __ ] from him from the 80s he's
so alive he's so ballsy so reckless it
was [ __ ] awesome it was like that old
school comedy where he just
he grabbed the camera and ah you know it
was very like uh
erratic and fun
he had uh he had a wife and kids yeah
so you know thoughts with him that's
horrible his wife is super nice super
cool yeah
damn oh there's bob saget and uh
wow
bob saget norm louis anderson now
gilbert
who am i
man
shout out to artie lange once again
hanging strong
you gotta give it to him